- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is talk about the notion of equilibrium
in a macroeconomics context.
So let's review a little bit
of what we've already studied
about aggregate demand
and aggregate supply.
So this vertical axis here,
that is the price level
for the economy that
we are trying to study,
and this horizontal axis right over here,
this would be the real
GDP for that economy,
the real GDP,
and now I could draw an
aggregate demand curve.
In previous videos we've talked at length
why economists like to model
it as a downward-sloping curve,
but once again,
take all of these things
with a grain of salt.
There's a lot of assumptions baked in,
and then I could also
draw aggregate supply,
aggregate supply.
This would be short-run aggregate supply,
upward-sloping curve,
so I'll just call that
short-run aggregate supply,
and I'll call that short-run
aggregate supply one,
'cause we might look at
other potential aggregate supply curves,
I could also look at
other potential aggregate demand curves,
but let's just do that for now.
So given these curves,
what would be the price
level and the level of output
for this economy?
Pause this video and think about it.
Well, some of you all might
just very naturally say,
well, it would be the
output and the price level
that corresponds to this
point of intersection,
and if you said that,
you would be correct.
So this would be our
short-run equilibrium output,
let me label that.
So that right over there
is our short-run equilibrium,
equilibrium,
equilibrium output
corresponds to where the
short-run aggregate supply
intersects to the aggregate demand curve,
and then this right over here
would be our equilibrium price level.
Let's call that PL1.
Now why do we feel good
that this would be the
short-run equilibrium output
and this would be the price level?
Well, let's imagine what would happen
if we were at a lower price level,
let's say right over here.
At that price level, we
see that aggregate demand
is outstripping aggregate supply.
The output that the aggregate demand wants
is much higher than the
output of the aggregate
the short-run aggregate supply,
and so that would be a shortage situation.
There's not enough output
for all of that demand,
and what would likely
happen in that situation?
Well, the folks producing that
output would probably say,
hey, I'm gonna charge a
little bit more for my output,
and as they're charging more they'll say,
hey, maybe I'll also produce
a little bit more output,
and they'll move up the curve
towards that equilibrium point,
and then on the demand
side, people would say,
hey, I'm not getting the output I need.
I'm willing to pay more for it,
but as the cost of that output
also goes up, the demand,
the output demanded would go down,
and we'd end up back at
that equilibrium point,
and we could do the same
thought exercise if,
for some reason we were at
a price level above PL1.
In this situation, aggregate supply,
short-run aggregate supply
is a good bit higher
than aggregate demand,
and so you have more output
than what is being demanded,
and so what's likely to happen?
Well, the suppliers,
the people producing the output, will say,
well, I'm gonna charge a
little bit less for my output,
and produce less,
and then similarly,
those demanding will say,
hey, there's this glut of output.
I'm gonna pay less for that output,
but as they're able to pay
less for it, they'll say,
hey, I want more and more of it,
and we get back to the equilibrium point.
Now, what we've talked about
so far is in the short run,
but some of you might be saying,
well, what about the long run?
And in previous videos
we have talked about
long-run aggregate supply,
and so let's say that this
curve right over here represents
the long-run aggregate supply curve,
and where it intersects the
horizontal axis, this Yf,
you could view this as
the output of this economy
at full employment,
and it's really the sustainable output
of this economy at full employment,
and so what's going on in
the graph right over here,
our equilibrium output is
well, our short-run equilibrium output
is below our full employment output,
and so we have a gap.
So there's a negative to go
from our full employment output
to our equilibrium output,
and so if we wanted to think about this
in the context of the business cycle,
where would we be on it?
So let's draw the business cycle.
So now I'll make the vertical
axis the level of real output.
So this would be real GDP right over here,
and then on the horizontal axis,
this will be the passage of time.
That is time, and so what typically
So at any given point in
time, there will be a Yf.
There will be some
sustainable potential output
for that economy,
and when I say sustainable it means,
you know, people are sleeping
properly, resting properly,
you're not unsustainably
depleting resources,
and so, for example,
at this point in time,
that might be the Yf,
and that may be a few years later.
Maybe the population has grown,
there's more infrastructure,
technology's improved.
So now they can sustainably produce more,
and then a few years after that,
maybe they could produce even more.
Population grows,
they've thought about better ways
to arrange the resources in their economy,
technology improves,
and so you could imagine a world
where that full employment output
could just grow in a
very nice way like this,
where it could just grow nicely like this,
but we know that's not the
way real economies work.
They experience the business cycle,
and the business cycle
looks more like this.
So it will look more like this,
where you have your
peaks and these troughs,
a boom-and-bust cycle, sometimes
people will talk about it,
and the parts of this curve
where you have increasing
real GDP, like there,
or there, or there, we
would call those expansions.
So that is economic expansion,
and the parts where GDP is receding.
So for example, right over
here, right over here,
we would call those recessions,
recessions,
but let's go back to our aggregate demand
and aggregate supply
world right over here.
This equilibrium point, Y1,
what point could that correspond to
on this graph right over
here of the business cycle?
And let me label that.
This is the business
the business cycle.
Pause this video.
Think about what point
it could correspond to.
Well, we're at a point
where a short-run equilibrium output
is below our full employment output,
our potential output,
our sustainable full potential output.
So this would correspond to some point
where our real GDP is sitting
below this blue curve,
or this blue line the way I've drawn it,
and so Y1 could, for
example, be this point,
or it could be that point,
and so if it was this one right over here,
then that right over there would be Y1
and this right over here would be the Yf,
would be the Yf for this point in time.
Now, as we go forward in time, this Yf,
we see this economic growth,
it could move to the right,
as population grows, as
we have better technology,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera,
but you're probably thinking,
well, what about other points?
Are there other possible scenarios?
And my answer to you would be absolutely.
So you could imagine a world
where the equilibrium output
is to the right of our potential output,
and I will construct that
by making a different short-run
aggregate supply curve,
although I could also do that
by shifting the aggregate demand curve,
and we'll do that in future videos,
but imagine a situation like this,
imagine.
So I'll call this short-run
aggregate supply two,
and now this is our equilibrium,
equilibrium output, Y2,
and it corresponds to price level,
price level two right over here,
and notice, here there's a
gap, but it's a positive gap.
Our actual output is above
our sustainable output,
and so for example,
this could correspond to maybe this point.
If it does correspond to this point,
so if this was Y2, then this
would be our current Yf.
I didn't actually shift it,
but hopefully you're
getting the general idea,
and you're saying,
well, how can you produce
beyond full employment?
How can you produce beyond
your sustainable potential?
Well, this is an economy
that is producing output
in an unsustainable way.
Unemployment is unusually low.
You have, maybe, depleting resources.
People are working too hard.
They're getting stressed out.
They're not sleeping properly.
However you wanna think about it,
it's not considered sustainable,
and then you have a third scenario
where your short-run equilibrium output
actually equals your
full employment output,
and so that could be this
scenario right over here.
So this would be our short-run
aggregate supply three,
and notice over here, our
equilibrium output, Y3,
is equal to our full employment output,
and when this happens,
this is considered a long-run equilibrium.
So let me write that down.
That is considered a long-run equilibrium,
equilibrium,
and points that correspond
to long-run equilibria
on this business cycle right over here
would be this point right over there,
and that point, and that
point, and that point.
So I'll leave you there.
In future videos,
we will actually think
about how aggregate demand
and short-run aggregate supply will shift,
and connect it even further
to the cycles in the business cycle.